nos preguntan cuál de las siguientes
estrategias eliminaría una variable del
sistema de ecuaciones elige todas las
que apliquen y bueno la primera dice
sumar las ecuaciones pausa el vídeo y
piensa si al sumar las ecuaciones
eliminamos una de las variables en este
sistema bien vamos a hacerlo juntos qué
sucede si sumamos estas ecuaciones bueno
del lado izquierdo obtenemos 5 x + 5 x
que es 10 x después tengo menos 3 yemas
4 james lo cual es más 1 james o
simplemente james es igual a menos 3 + 6
lo cual es 3 observa no eliminamos
ninguna variable así que podemos
cancelar el inciso am ya que no
eliminamos a ninguna variable inciso b
restar la ecuación de abajo a la
ecuación de arriba
bueno si restamos la ecuación de abajo a
la de arriba obtengo que 5 x 5 x eso nos
queda 0 x así que no la escribiré y
podemos ver que ya eliminamos a x así
que me parece que esta es la opción
correcta después tengo que menos 3 menos
4 james es lo mismo que menos 7 james y
menos 3 menos 6 es lo mismo que menos 9
así que ya está el inciso b elimina una
variable de manera exitosa que es justo
lo que queríamos así que voy a
seleccionar este inciso
incisos en multiplicar la ecuación de
arriba por 2 y después sumar las dos
ecuaciones pausa el vídeo y pregúntate
será que esta estrategia elimina una
variable bueno multipliquemos la
ecuación de arriba por 2 y me queda 10 x
menos 6 bien igual a menos 6 y ya puedes
ver que si las sumamos con la ecuación
de abajo no se eliminará ninguna
variable 10 x 5 x eso es 15 x esta
variable no se elimina menos 6 yemas 4
jeff es lo mismo que menos 2 james
entonces tampoco se eliminan y ya
podemos cancelar también este inciso
bien hagamos otro ejemplo nos hacen la
misma pregunta cuál de las siguientes
estrategias eliminaría una variable del
sistema de ecuaciones y el primer inciso
dice multiplicar la ecuación de abajo
por 2 y después sumar las dos ecuaciones
pausa el vídeo
esto funciona
bien si multiplicamos la ecuación de
abajo por 2 obtenemos 2x -4 y estoy
multiplicando todo por 2 es igual a 10
después si sumamos las ecuaciones
obtengo que 4 x 2 x es 6 x así que ésta
no se elimina 4 y menos 4 james ok esto
es 0 y entonces la variable si se
elimina cuando sumas 4 yemas menos 4 y
esto se va y entonces el inciso a me
agrada muy bien
qué hay del inciso b pausa el vídeo y
dime funciona
bueno dice multiplicar la ecuación de
abajo por 4 y después restar la ecuación
de abajo a la ecuación de arriba
bueno multiplicamos la ecuación de abajo
por 4 que obtenemos 4x menos 8 y es
igual a 20 bien ya la multiplique y
ahora hay que restar la de la ecuación
de arriba si restamos 4x menos 4 x bien
eso se ve bien eso elimina las x así que
este también es un inciso correcto y
después puedes ver que el restar menos 8
y de 4 james bueno restar un negativo es
lo mismo que sumar el valor pero
positivo eso nos llevaría a 12 y si
restamos 20 de menos 2 obtenemos menos
22 y podemos ver que ya con el hecho de
que 4x menos 4x se eliminan entonces es
un inciso correcto en definitiva
eliminamos una variable por lo tanto me
agrada el psis opea
insisto se multiplicar la ecuación de
arriba por un medio y después sumar las
dos ecuaciones vamos a intentarlo para
os el vídeo
bien vamos a multiplicar por un medio
por lo tanto el lado izquierdo por un
medio si distribuimos en un medio me
queda 4x por un medio
eso es 2x más 4 por un medio eso es lo
mismo que 2 es igual a menos 2 por un
medio lo cual es menos 1 ok
después dice sumar las ecuaciones
tengo que 2 x x es 3x esta variable no
se eliminan después tengo 2 yemas menos
2 y bueno aquí me quedo sin variable y
esto el efecto elimina a las 10 así que
también me agrada ese inciso de hecho
esta vez las 3 son estrategias que
eliminan una variable en el sistema de
ecuaciones y esto es muy útil puedes ver
que existen varias formas de resolver el
sistema de ecuaciones por eliminación
ahora hagamos otro ejemplo más
la misma pregunta de nuevo así que el
inciso a dice restar la ecuación de
abajo de la ecuación de arriba pausa el
vídeo esto funciona
bueno si restamos la ecuación de abajo a
la de arriba entonces restar menos 2x es
lo mismo que sumar 2x
si sumas 2 x 3 x 5 x por lo que la
variable x no se elimina si restamos 4 y
menos 3 y obtienes menos 7 james la
variable y tampoco se elimina así que
voy a cancelar este inciso ninguna
variable se elimina en este inciso
bien inciso b multiplicar la ecuación de
arriba por 3 multiplicar la ecuación de
abajo por todos y después sumar las dos
ecuaciones pausa el vídeo
esto funciona
bueno si multiplicó la ecuación de
arriba por 3 obtengo 9 x menos 9 y es
igual que 21 y después dice multiplica
la cuestión de abajo por 2 por lo tanto
tengo 2 x menos 2 x es menos 4 x más 8 y
james es igual a 14 y después nos dice
sumar las dos ecuaciones bueno muchísimo
9 x con menos 4 x eso no va a eliminar
las x ya que da de resultado 5 x
positivo si sumo menos 9 y a 8
tampoco eliminó las 10 ya que eso me
queda menor james así que también puedo
descartar la opción b
bien ahora veamos la opción multiplicar
la ecuación de arriba por 2 multiplicar
la ecuación de abajo por 3 y después
sumar las dos ecuaciones ok ahora nos
dicen que hagamos lo mismo cambiando los
números pausa el vídeo e inténtalo por
tu cuenta
voy a multiplicar la ecuación de arriba
por 2 y la de abajo por 3
entonces la ecuación de arriba por 2 es
6x menos 6 que es igual a 14
y ahora si multiplicamos la ecuación de
abajo por 3 de ambos lados para
asegurarnos que la ecuación resultante
es la misma es por eso que multiplicamos
de ambos lados de la ecuación esto es
realmente el corazón del álgebra
entonces me va a quedar menos 2x por 3
es menos 6x y esto empieza agradar ya
que al sumar estas dos se van a eliminar
más 4 por 3 es 12 que es igual a 21 y
después dice sumar las dos ecuaciones
pero de manera inmediata puedes ver que
al sumar las ecuaciones la variable x se
cancela así que me agrada el cis ósea